abbas m bonjour alors un point presse a
eu lieu en début d'après midi que
faut-il en retenir
effectivement un point presse a eu lieu
ici tribunal de woolwich dans le sud de
londres pour ce procès hors norme celui
de julian assange eu un point presse qui
a été donné par le rédacteur en chef de
wikileaks par l'avocate de julian
assange et par le père julian assange
qui sont venus sur c'est un jour et demi
d'audience car la scie encore la pause
déjeuner la deuxième partie de
l'audience n'a pas encore repris son
revenu sur le plan de la baie la
plaidoirie des américains jugeant que
julian assange avait conspiré il est
poursuivi pour des publications qui date
de 2010 qu'il aurait mis en danger des
sources
et puis à des témoins qu'il aurait
divulgué des documents classés top
secret par les américains les américains
qui demandent son extradition et sont
venus également sur les conditions de
détention ils ont dit qu'ils avaient une
succession de mensonges durant ces
audiences de la part des américains que
julian assange ne faisait que son
travail et qui devait continuer de jouir
de cette liberté d'expression et la
liberté de la presse par dont je vous
propose d'écouter le rédacteur en chef
de wikileaks
nous sommes dans le contexte d'un empire
abusifs qui ré poste qui veut se venger
sur une base politique pour faire un
exemple de julian assange pour faire un
exemple de lui pour effrayer les autres
journalistes qui veulent faire leur
travail en particulier ceux qui
s'intéressent aux problèmes de sécurité
tout ce procès auquel nous assistons
n'est compréhensible que si on prend en
compte la présence de forces obscures
qui tentent d'étouffer et de faire taire
ceux qui veulent mettre en lumière les
actions néfastes de cet empire une
violation de la liberté d'expression
relation de la liberté d'exercer la
profession de journaliste elle été les
mots du rédacteur de wikileaks durant ce
point presse pendant la pause déjeuner
les revenu également sur les conditions
de détention de julian assange
ici à londres décrivant des conditions
inhumaines un manque de respect de sa
dignité lors été menotté on soit d
habiller deux fois on l'aurait enlevée
ses effets personnels juste
avant l'audience il a parlé d'un julian
assange qui s'est présenté à la barre
très affaiblie affaibli par ses
conditions de détention ici je vous
rappelle qu'il est détenu à londres
depuis avril dernier après avoir passé
sept ans dans l'ambassade et d'équateur
ici à l'ondé américains demandent son
extradition son avocate a même dit que
le faire extrader le faire aller aux
états unis et pour un procès cela
viendrait à de violer la liberté
d'expression et surtout la liberté 2
julian assange vous rappelle et qu'ils
encourent jusqu'à 175 années de prison
pour 18 chefs d'accusation si bien sûr
la cour londonienne accepte cette
extradition vers les etats-unis merci
beaucoup aux basses m ben hassen chébili
en direct de londres